you've done something that is pretty
extraordinary
you've made a movie
and you made a movie that's about you
and your father
and it's called about my father and as I
mentioned earlier there's so much to
talk about here but you did an
extraordinary thing you you cast and
when I say cast
it'd make it sound like De Niro was
hoping he got the part
did you give me the audition
try it again Bob Bob try it again Bob
it's between you and two other guys but
I think you did a pretty good job
um you get Robert De Niro to pay to play
your dad now
how surreal is this
it's got to be surreal for you but what
about your father what does your father
think about Robert De Niro playing him
yeah so we wrote the movie my writing
partner Austin Earl and I wrote the
movie we kind of um have the same
pattern of of life in in the sense that
we've been both married into money and
we've always kind of wrote about this
life of two guys who kind of married a
better cut of cloth in our wives so uh
the movie kind of centers around my
father and I going to a country club
environment which I do every summer my
wife uh family has a home in North
Carolina that we go to
Country Club very white you know when I
show up I look like I I cut the lawn I'm
like I'm I'm dark you know what I'm
saying
so uh sometimes you do cut the line just
because you're like I think I could do
that better than that guy
so it's just kind of these two worlds
kind of colliding the movie centers
around that but uh my the Nero listen we
never set out to to get him we didn't
write the movie with him in mind you
just don't even think that's a
possibility right and then once I worked
with him in the Irishman and then he
subsequently came to see me do comedy at
Radio City Music Hall he came backstage
we talked a little bit and I'm sure
you've met the man he's he's not like
highly engaging as far as conversation
he's you know kind of quiet to himself
so it's not like you know I we had wine
together I don't have wine with nobody
um so it's not like we had like a social
relationship but
um we sent them the script and he really
gravitated towards it and he wanted to
read it out loud with a bunch of actors
so we sat down we did a table read and
then after that he made the decision
that he wanted to do it now De Niro
being the guy the actor that he is
wanted to hang out with my Dad wow right
now that's crazy yeah because he's his
method he wants to he you know this is
about your dad he wants to spend time
with your dad and absorb yeah this uh
man's characteristics yeah
yeah so they get on the phone uh and he
wants him to come to Oklahoma where De
Niro is shooting the movie with Scorsese
and DiCaprio
my dad who's a hair stylist is going to
go uh first he's bitching that he's got
to take off work
for this yeah I got
bad job and a blowout on Friday
he has priorities
so uh he goes to Oklahoma and he goes to
De Niro's home there that is rented for
the the movie and De Niro's asking him
when you when you wear your hand how you
wear your hat and then my father's like
oh I wear it like this and then when you
smoke a cigar how do you how do you
smoke it then he wanted to know some
Italian Sicilian slang
that the Nero wanted to put in there and
you know and I'm I'm dying to hear how
this is going I mean you have to
understand this is a guy that had
posters on my wall growing up the narrow
of course yeah Casino Good Fellas my dad
and I watch this guy no no he's playing
my father so
for me I'm trying to wrap my head around
it so afterwards I said you got to call
me as soon as you get out of there all
right so he calls I go how was it yeah
how was it
I come here four hours
my dad's bitching about the hours
wow then he's asking me you know like am
I getting pain looking like a little
something for this I got that I don't
that's so perfect you know like I mean
listen he was he was I mean he was
beside himself yeah but you know there's
also that you know way we grew up of
sure I'm gonna lose clients and I'm here
and this and that the other thing then
he's on set because the Niro one of them
set because there's a there's a scene in
the movie where we're in a hair salon
and De Niro being the actor that is
wanted to know how to do a die job with
the foil so my dad is teaching De Niro
the the foil and this and that I'm
looking at this going this is the salon
looked like the salon I grew up in with
my father and now he's teaching De Niro
how to do hair and I'm like I was just
so proud that my dad was alive to see
this all going down right
so the narrow didn't want him to leave
to set yeah where are you going he's
like I go back to work I'm a little
after work eh tomorrow we got another
scene and Dad's like
I gotta pump
so that's fantastic yeah
so now
that they want to use my father in a lot
of this promotion that we're doing for
the movie so we're doing uh my father
and I are going on Kimmel right together
and uh you know this is like my father's
really excited about him being involved
in the Press yeah which I was nervous
about because my father's the type of
guy or when we're hanging around a group
of people he's life at a party as soon
as the camera pops on him he kind of
goes into a shell however we did a press
event in Las Vegas and they were asking
him questions and I was like well this
guy's like my dad speaks broken English
because you know he's from Sicily and
he's answering questions I'm like okay
we need a camera on him to speak proper
English I mean
oh suddenly suddenly suddenly
pronouncing words right right
so uh he's another enunciator
get another enunciator
that's fantastic that's fantastic yeah
so yeah we uh we Shot the movie in
Alabama which was difficult for me just
because I got two small kids I was gonna
be there for eight weeks
and you know I was wrestling with like
oh God you know like again me thinking
overthinking things this is a great
opportunity yes but then I'm also
thinking I should be home I'm gonna find
there what the hell am I doing in
Alabama you know gotta be with my kids
but uh
I don't know what you're talking about
uh that's all
those kids do better when I'm not around
they Thrive when I'm not
yeah but I know what you mean I know
what you mean yeah I mean I have a
family guy so anyway it was an
unbelievable experience it was a acting
lesson
for me for seven eight weeks what
however long we shot this movie there
was a time where I had to cry no listen
I'm a sensitive guy I could cry you know
in just conversation
but to do it like in a movie I never did
this before and now I'm doing it with
arguably one of the best actors of our
time he comes right and when he's
supposed to cry in the scene he's crying
right and I ain't crying
I go where is it it ain't coming and I'm
looking at him like uh like almost like
a fan I go this guy's crying on you
can't you just grab one of his tears
that's what I would do the minute no
one's looking get a De Niro tear yeah I
was hoping I could get some spill off
but uh
and then they said cut and then did it
again still didn't cry and then I told
him I go bro I gotta talk to you man I I
need help here so me and him privately
going there was an airplane it was an
airplane scene we go into the airplane
together and I go I can't I can't get
there and he goes well I didn't know you
know I was gonna tell you you know I'm
gonna give you some advice but I didn't
know your process there ain't no process
guys I'm just hoping this Clicks in
Sword you know there's no method or
nothing right there I'm just doing the
lines hoping I can get sad
that is the method actually
so uh so we gave you advice yeah no he's
like what I do is I think of my son and
and he in in in in in telling me the
story he starts crying oh my God
now I'm crying because he's crying about
talking about his son I gotta use this
and I I I get out of the plane
and I'm supposed to be out of breath
during the scene now I got sciatica
ripping through my right leg right and I
don't really run because of the pain now
I'm running crying with sciatica on a
Tarmac trying to get out of breath right
so I come into the scene and I'm crying
already but I'm not supposed to be but
I'm like it this you know use this
yeah yeah I'm balling
throughout this cut all right we're
gonna do it again again guys that's all
I got we're gonna do it again and do
this nine times you need to rehydrate
[Laughter]